We have a really serious situation of authoritarianism
that ties into suppression of speech, actual
suppression of speech.
It possibly ties into the plan to steal this
election in November by Donald Trump.
And what's happening is that paramilitary
federal law enforcement officers have been
dispatched to Portland, Oregon.
They're grabbing people, including protesters,
not just looters.
They're taking them away in unmarked vehicles.
They don't have badges.
And this has been confirmed by the Department
of Homeland Security.
This is really actually serious.
These paramilitaries are driving around in
unmarked cars wearing camouflage, really more
appropriate for the desert than downtown Portland,
Oregon.
Protesters are being detained even in the
absence of evidence that any crime was committed.
And this is an authoritarian type show of
force.
The claim from Department of Homeland Security
is that these troops, which really is what
they are, are being sent to Portland to keep
the peace and to protect federal property.
The stories we're hearing are that people
are being grabbed, thrown in unmarked vans,
taken to undisclosed locations, not being
accused of any crime.
In many cases, some are.
And in most cases they are being released.
Some are charged with crimes.
Some of the people being detained are not
even near federal property, which is supposedly
the reason these federal troops are there
in the first place.
And many aren't being told why they are being
detained.
They are just protesters protected by the
First Amendment.
The mayor of Portland, Ted Wheeler, says he
didn't ask for help.
He has asked the federal troops to leave,
and yet there they are.
So that's story number one.
What is actually happening on the ground?
And we're still getting more information about
what's happening there.
The second story is that this is potentially
a test of what may happen in many cities starting
as soon as this week to repress protests.
Charlie Pierce has a good piece about this
in Esquire, where he points out when Trump
tries something and gets away with it, he
does more of it.
And Pierce is suggesting maybe this is a dry
run for what Trump was threatening at the
start of the George Floyd protests a couple
of months ago.
Major deployments of militarized law enforcement
or even straight up military to urban areas.
So there's two substories to that second story.
Number one is the authoritarianism spreading
to repress protests.
The second part is actually trying to cause
confrontations.
The troops, that is in order to benefit Trump
politically by pointing to violent protesters,
which they will induce to violence.
We've already seen reports that the protests,
the protests themselves are seeing more unrest
in Portland since the deployment of the troops.
So there's the authoritarianism.
But there's also the deployment of troops
to create unrest, to then point to look at
all these violent people.
We need a bigger show of force, which gets
us to the third piece of this, which is these
authoritarian forces being sent into cities
now could be a trial balloon for sending or
keeping them in cities in November for the
purpose of intimidating around the election.
And that would be like the closure of the
loop in terms of what's going on.
That strategy requires some foresight, which
Trump does not seem able to do.
But William Barr certainly would be capable
of that.
And some of the others involved may well be.
Now, in terms of legality, of course, Trump's
Justice Department and DHS say this is legal.
The ACLU and other lawyers have said, you
know this.
This could arguably be kidnaping and abduction.
Right.
I mean, you've got paramilitaries without
badges and cammo in unmarked cars, grabbing
people, taking them away, often not telling
them what crime they're suspected of committing
and eventually releasing them without having
charged them of any crime.
It is going in the direction of a secret police
sort of thing.
Now to take a brief detour.
This is important as an opportunity to prepare
you for some bad arguments from the right
about this right wing darling Ben Shapiro
tweeted in response to some of what we're
seeing in Portland, quote, Fascism is not
federal law enforcement enforcing the law
against rioters and looters and they are arresting
rioters and looters in Portland.
Not mere protesters.
Fascism is the Chinese government shuttling
wiggers by train to concentration camps?
Well, he's right that that certainly is fascistic.
What's.
Going on in China and everybody should be
calling it out and and most people are, but
there is a petri dish of nonsense here.
It's almost like a one sentence Gish Gallop,
because a lot of stuff is being mixed up.
It is true that law enforcement arresting
criminals is not fascism.
That that that's completely true.
That's not actually what's at issue here.
What we have here are countless videos of
mere protesters being brutally repressed,
who have not looted, who have not rioted.
We have law enforcement in unmarked cars popping
out in a city in cammo.
That does not match the urban setting in which
they're operating, wearing desert cammo without
badges.
That is deliberate intimidation that's starting
to border on some of the stuff you see in
authoritarian and totalitarian states.
And to top it off, there are reports coming
in of people being taken off to undisclosed
locations, not being given due process, just
being held and ultimately released.
So don't fall for law enforcement doing law
enforcement work.
Isn't fascism.
No, it's not.
That's not what this is about.
This is about camouflaged military in unmarked
vehicles sent in to repress protests, possibly
as a trial balloon for intimidation to happen
nationally as we approach Election Day.
We almost have a situation where Portland,
Portland police officers should be protecting
protesters from the guys with no badges in
the unmarked vans.
That's how crazy it is.
Don't we have a right to know who is policing
us?
Aren't combattants as insane as that word
is required to indicate who they are and who
they work for?
Anonymous police and cammo with no badges
is what's going on right now.
This could just as easily be some right wing
militia as it could be a prison riot squad
being repurposed.
And in fact, how long will it be until some
right wing militia that looks just like these
guys kidnaps and kills someone and it gets
swept under the rug?
This city should file a lawsuit and put it
in the hands of the courts.
I'd be lying if I said I knew how the courts
would rule on what's going on.
This is still developing.
We will have more upcoming.